bien en este vídeo yo quiero hablarles
acerca de radiales y acerca de grados
ver que tienen en común los radiales y
los grados y además platicarles acerca
de todo lo que hemos venido viendo en
grados y en radiales quiero hacer un
repaso general de todo lo que hemos
visto así que veamos tenemos aquí un
ángulo de 90 grados
este es un ángulo de 90 grados y es una
medida angular es decir la apertura que
hay entre estas dos líneas es de 90
grados
aquí tenemos uno de la mitad de 45
grados y por ejemplo si tenemos una
vuelta entera y la queremos medir en
grados vamos a tener 360 grados bueno
esta es la medida usual que usamos al
hablar de ángulos dos grados sin embargo
también hay otra forma de medir los
ángulos que son los radiales y en este
vídeo quiero hablarles bastante de lo
que son los radiales así que déjenme
borrar esto y déjenme platicarles un
poco de los radiales a ver si yo déjenme
hacer un círculo para que me entiendan
mucho mejor qué es un radiante entonces
voy a tomar mi herramienta de los
círculos aquí están el círculo y ahora
voy a dibujar su centro
este de aquí changos no no no no no
quería hacer un círculo quiero hacer un
centro este de aquí este va a ser mi
centro y por lo tanto voy a decir que
este va a ser mi radio están de acuerdo
si este es un centro y este es mi radio
entonces yo defino a un radian como una
medida angular como un ángulo pero como
un ángulo muy especial voy a llamarle a
este ángulo theta un radial si este
ángulo sub tiende un arco que tenga como
longitud un radio es decir la longitud
de este arco tiene que ser igual a un
radio es decir lo mismo que vale el
radio la misma longitud y si eso pasa
entonces digo que este es un ángulo de
un radio z sería un radial y esto me da
pie a que lo pensemos un poco más
profundo y veamos de dónde sale la
igualdad más importante de grados a
radiales fíjense bien yo aquí tengo un
círculo déjenme dibujar lea aquí el
radio este es el centro este es el radio
y ahora mi pregunta es si este ángulo es
de un radial
si este ángulo tiene una medida de un
radial que es lo que significaba eso
recuerden estoy pensando que este ángulo
sub tiende un arco de longitud de un
radio entonces esto va a ser un radial
mi pregunta es cuántos radiales caben en
una circunferencia entera o dicho otra
manera cuántos radiales hay en una
vuelta completa y esa es mi pregunta que
tengo para resolver esta pregunta es muy
sencillo pensarla de la siguiente manera
fíjense bien yo voy a ver cuál es el
perímetro de una circunferencia cuál es
el perímetro de la circunferencia bueno
el perímetro se saca multiplicando dos
veces pi por el radio es decir que la
longitud de una circunferencia es dos
veces pi por el radio pero sí un radial
es el ángulo que se tiende una a cuya
longitud es un radio por lo tanto si yo
le quiero dar una vuelta entera esta
circunferencia voy a tener también dos
pi radian es como medida angular y ojo
un radial no es lo mismo que un radio un
radial es una medida angular
mientras que aquí use el radio como una
medida de longitud hay una gran
diferencia sin embargo ya sé cuánto vale
darle una vuelta entera a una
circunferencia en radiales y por lo
tanto esto me da pie a pensar en la
igualdad más importante para pasar de
grados radiales y de radiales sagrados
la cual vamos a utilizar cada vez que
nosotros queramos transformar estas dos
cantidades así que bueno espero que me
hayan entendido bien esto porque voy a
borrar esta pantalla y ahora quiero
utilizar un poco lo que acabo de
aprender fíjense bien darle una vuelta
entera a una circunferencia o dar una
vuelta entera es tener dos radiales esto
lo vimos justo en la pantalla anterior
pero por otra parte yo sé que dará una
vuelta entera en grados es lo mismo que
360 grados están de acuerdo
360 grados y por lo tanto ya tengo una
igualdad
yo sé que dos pies radiales es lo mismo
que dar una vuelta entera que son
iguales a 360 grados ahora si yo he
vivido ambas partes de la igualdad entre
dos pipas saca el valor de un radial me
va a quedar que un ryan es igual a 360
grados entre 2 pib o dicho de otra
manera
180 / p grados y esto me da el valor de
cuánto vale exactamente un radiante si
yo divido 180 entre pi en grados es el
valor de un radial y de igual manera si
yo quisiera saber el valor de un grado
en variantes pues esto es lo mismo que 2
y entre 360 solamente estoy pasando del
otro lado dividiendo el 360 2 pie entre
360 radiales lo cual es lo mismo que pie
entre 180 radian es un grado vale y
entre 180 radiales y ya con esto tengo
una analogía o una igualdad de un radio
han dado en grados y de un grado dado en
radiales esto me va a ayudar a poder
transformar cualquier cantidad de grados
arrayanes y cualquier cantidad de
radiales a grados y todo sale de esta
igualdad que es importantísima es la
igualdad más importante para transformar
de grados a radiales y de radiales a
grados pues esto está perfecto así que
vamos a estrenar esta fórmula y no
forzosamente te tienes que aprender todo
esto de memoria si te lo quisieras
aprender de memoria sería muy pesado
pero lo que sí te puedes aprender es lo
siguiente si le doy media vuelta
completa a una circunferencia x
aparte yo sé que tengo 180 grados eso es
lo que sabemos pero además sé que por
otra parte medido en radiales esto es lo
mismo que pi radiales
porque si le doy toda la vuelta completa
a una circunferencia son tus pies
radiales
le doy media vuelta pues voy a tener
irradian es la mitad y de aquí yo puedo
esperar tanto los grados o los radiales
dependiendo de qué sea lo que necesite
por ejemplo aquí un radiante es igual a
180 entre pi grados o un grado es
igualdad pi entre 180 radiales así que
veamos varios ejemplos para ver cómo
transformó de grados radiales y de
radiales sagrados supongamos que yo
quiero transformar 45 grados a radiales
como le voy a hacer bueno lo primero que
tengo que hacer es guardar la calma
respirar profundo y fijarme que yo lo
que quiero pasar es de grados a radiales
por lo tanto necesito saber cuánto vale
un grado en radiales pero un grado es lo
mismo que pi entre 180 radiales por lo
tanto si sustituyó me quedaría que 45
grados
es lo mismo que 45 por pi entre 180
radiales lo único que estoy haciendo es
sustituyendo
cuál es el valor de un grado en radiales
y por lo tanto 45 entre 180 es un cuarto
por fin me quedan cuartos radiales y que
creen ya encontré mi primer ejercicio de
pasar de grados a radiales y se podrá al
revés podría ello transformar de
radiales a grados pues vamos a
intentarlo pero antes de pasar a la
siguiente pantalla lo que sí quiero que
vean es que lo único que hice fue
sustituir cuánto valía un grado en
radiales si yo quiero pasar de grados a
radiales tengo que sustituir el valor de
un grado y recuerdan que no esfuerzos
memorizar todas estas dos igualdades que
yo tengo aquí aunque yo memorice esta
que está acá arriba
esta es la igualdad más importante que
hay en grados y en radiales
ya con esto ya le dice entonces vamos a
ver ahora quiero pasar y medios radiales
a grados y medios radiales a grados como
le voy a hacer se podrá acaso y la
respuesta es que sí se pueden como lo
voy a hacer recordando primero la
igualdad más importante que tengo
irradian es es lo mismo que 180 grados
vamos a escribirlo irradian es es igual
a 180 grados esta igualdad es
importantísima para saber cómo pasar de
grados radiales y yo ahora lo que voy a
querer despejar es el valor de un
radiante porque si puedo saber cuánto
balón radiante entonces puede sustituir
aquí arriba y ya hubiese acabado
entonces un radial es igual a 180 grados
entre fin recuerden que si yo paso
dividiendo el pie del otro lado me va a
quedar que un solo radial y entre pies
uno es igual a 180 entre pipas el pie
dividiendo un radiantes 180 entre pi
grados muy bien
ya tengo cuánto vale un radio en grados
ahora lo que voy a hacer es sustituirlo
aquí arriba como yo quiero el valor en
grados lo que tengo que hacer es
sustituir el valor de un radio aquí
arriba y un radiantes 180 entre grados
entonces tengo mil medios radiales y
esto lo quiero pasar a grados pues
entonces voy a multiplicar a pi medios
por lo que vale un radial un ryan son
180 entre grados y entonces ya se pueden
ir algunas cosas picón pisaban 182 me da
90 y al final tengo 90 grados
es decir que medios radiales es ni más
ni menos que 90 grados un ángulo recto
como lo conocemos a ver vamos al otro
ejercicio qué les parece si yo quiero
transformar 30 grados arrayanes 30
grados a radiales y cómo le voy a hacer
ya estas alturas ya sabemos bien qué es
lo que tenemos que hacer lo primero es
poner la igualdad más importante que
tenemos pri radiales es igual a 180
grados yo lo que quiero despejar de aquí
son a los grados porque quiero saber
cuánto vale un grado por lo tanto un
grado es igual a pi entre 180 radiales y
después solamente sustituyó esto es lo
mismo que 30 que multiplica a pie entre
180 radiales porque yo lo que quiero
llegar es a radiales al balón radiales y
ar zinc 30 entre 180 es lo mismo que un
sexto por lo tanto un sexto por pi es lo
mismo que pi sextos radiales y ya con
esto obtuve la transformación de otro
ejercicio de grados a radiales con
suerte y tienes una sensación muy
placentera de que ya sabes cómo
convertir de grados a radiales y de
radio nasa grados y además ya sabes por
qué un radian se llama un radial
así que
por ahora te dejo y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo